ja die nasa hat neue super spektakuläre
visionen verkündet die mit dem james
webb weltraumteleskop realität werden
könnten zwar verzögert sich der start
des weltraumteleskops immer und immer
wieder
trotzdem ist klar dass sich das warten
auf jeden fall lohnen wird denn das
riesen weltraumteleskop könnte mit
seiner achtung hundertfach besseren
auflösung im vergleich zum abel weltraum
teleskop die astronomie komplett
revolutionieren
jetzt haben seine zentralen elemente
weitere testläufe erfolgreich bestanden
willkommen bei klick zum science fiction
hier gibt's täglich faszinierendes
science videos abonniert den kanal nur
dann verpasst er nichts
vielen dank für diesen coolen
themenvorschlag den er mir über whatsapp
geschickt habt die liste ist lang das
was das james webb weltraumteleskop
kurze jwst alles ermöglichen könnte ist
echt der reine wahnsinn dass
riesenteleskop ist unter anderem ihr
speziell dafür entwickelt worden
außerirdisches leben zu suchen anders
als das hubble teleskop das im
sichtbaren ultravioletten und nahen
infraroten spektrum sucht ist das jwst
ein supertalent im infraroten bereich so
kann es beispielsweise die atmosphäre
von exoplaneten analysieren die wiederum
hinweise auf planet ares leben gibt die
satelliten und teleskope die wir derzeit
zur verfügung haben die sind dafür
einfach nicht leistungsstark genug aber
nicht nur dass fachleute erwarten
unglaubliche aufnahmen und erkenntnisse
zu sternen und planeten systemen und
zuletzt könnte das riesenteleskop auch
dazu beitragen endlich auch dem
mysteriösen rätsel um die dunkle materie
auf die spur zu kommen doch bislang
folgte ein rückschritt auf den nächsten
ursprünglich sollte das jwst schon 2014
mit einer ariane-5-trägerrakete straßen
doch der bau des teleskops wurde
aufgrund von enormen kosten unterbrochen
dann wurden technische mängel
festgestellt zuletzt im sommer 2008
zehnter fiel beim vibrations- tests auf
dass einige schrauben locker waren
wir hatten ja bei pixum science fiction
dollar berichtet und so wurde der neue
starttermin von mai 2020 auf dem 30
märz 2021 verlegt doch mit diesen ganzen
rückschlägen ist laut nasa jetzt schluss
anfang des jahres wurden wichtige
meilensteine erreicht unter anderem
bestand das sogenannte raumfahrt element
das riesenteleskop neue wirklich habe
vibrations- tests die nasa teams
überprüften damit ob die technik den
strapazen eines raketenabschusses in den
weltraum standhalten würde
denn beim abheben einer rakete entstehen
gigantische vibrationen und
energiereiche schallwellen die wiederum
auf die rakete treffen nachdem sie vom
boden und gebäuden abgeprallt sind genau
diese bedingungen wurden im test
simuliert und zwar mit massiven
lautsprechern und einem elektro
dynamischen schwingt tisch auf dem
einige elemente des teleskops kräftig
durchgeschüttelt worden
nach diesen mechanischen überprüfungen
steht noch ein weiterer test an der
zeigen soll ob das webb teleskop auch
dem vakuum und den temperaturen im
weltraum trotzen kann und diese tests
bedeuten einen enormen aufwand das
raumfahrzeug element muss dafür
zusammengeklappt werden genauso wie es
übrigens auch für den start vorgesehen
ist doch selbst in diesem verstauten
zustand ist es noch so groß auto wie ein
ganzer schult und dennoch muss dieses
element ja für die tests von einem ort
zum anderen bewegt werden die tests bei
denen die satelliten untersucht werden
laufen übrigens in sogenannten
reinräumen ab alle schädlichen
verunreinigungen selbst die kleinsten
staubkörner werden aus diesen räumen
heraus gefiltert damit die empfindlichen
instrumente auch ja nicht beschädigt
werden nach beendigung dieser letzten
test wird das james webb raumfahrzeug
element nach kalifornien gebracht wo es
dann mit dem teleskop element zu einer
einheit zusammengeführt wird dann ist
das jwst endlich startklar und schon
jetzt hat die nasa immer wieder neue
großartige ideen die mit dem
riesenteleskop verwirklicht werden
können beispielsweise soll mit seiner
hilfe das mysterium der jelly fish
galaxy also der sogenannten qualm
galaxie erforscht werden wenn die nasa
forschungsteams können sich bisher
einfach nicht erklären warum sich hinter
dem kopf dieser galaxie ein riesiger gas
schweiz befindet neugeborene blau
leuchtende sterne bilden quasi die
tentakeln der galaxie deswegen auch ihre
bezeichnung als quallen galaxie dazu die
nasa die neu entstehenden sternen
schweiz sind mysteriös
denn eigentlich erschweren bestimmte
prozesse in großen gruppen von galaxien
die bildung von neuen sternen extrem
entdeckt wurde dieser gigantische gas
schweifen mit der hilfe von
röntgenstrahlen
doch warum genau tritt er aus der
galaxie heraus und warum bilden sich
dort sterne bisher wissen wir nur dass
die quallen galaxie etwa so groß ist wie
unsere milchstraße er schweift also ihre
tentakeln sind dabei drei mal so großen
kopf aber auch in sachen supernova
explosionen soll uns das james webb
teleskop klüger machen
die nasa hat vor kurzem im februar 2009
10 verkündet dass vor allem die
supernova 1987 also es ändert 780
beobachtet werden soll
als 1987 aufgespürt wurde handelt es
sich um die hälse supernova seit 100
jahren
auch wenn ihr licht mittlerweile
verblasst ist könnten uns ihre überreste
verraten wie sterne leben und sterben
dazu die nasa mitarbeiterinnen olivia
jones wir haben keine ahnung woraus der
staub der supernova 987 a besteht wird
uns nicht nur die zusammensetzung des
staub sondern auch seine temperatur und
dichte des staubes näher bringen und
diese analyse wird sicherlich
folgenreiche erkenntnis mit sich bringen
den staub spielt eine wesentliche rolle
bei der entwicklung der nächsten
generation von sternen planeten und
galaxien wir können also gespannt sein
vor allem auf die untersuchung der
atmosphären von exoplaneten denn damit
könnte tatsächlich außerirdisches leben
aufgespürt werden ab 2021 gibt es mehr
zu berichten leben auf exoplaneten neue
erkenntnisse zur entstehung von leben
draufklicken hier anschauen und raumzeit
blockt der zukunft abonnieren bis dann
bleibt dran